would be
the longer answer will be provided that
the elections are going to be fair and
democratic in Ukraine there will be a
change of power in Ukraine and most
probably the new president will be the
traditional this is not a wishful
thinking this is the analysis of the
department opinion polls so which will
indicate that for almost three years the
tradition remains the most popular
politician in Ukraine with the
popularity the last the latest figures
twenty-four percent where the tire and
seven but next after him for many years
was the leader of the Communist simony
onco with some ten to twelve percent and
recently Yanukovych has come close
tradition with South twelve to fourteen
percent so provided that the recent
public opinion poll indicated that if
you Shinto and yellow polish will
the second realm of elections mission
cannot receive thirty percent and
encourage supporting yourself so a lot
has to be no covered in the wake of this
Court on presidential elections
certainly we the forces of the
Opposition are determined to work are in
order to secure the victory for our
candidate to Victor suddenly the
authorities which ma and his team they
are interested in repeating the scenario
of 99 elections that is to have somebody
from their camp and communist but most
most probably it will not be the case
most probably it will be victorious
condition for with salary from the from
Fujima yeah well there are some rumors
that which mom a run himself but it
would be well either the lack of
political realism or well
suicide because with such a low
popularity one cannot expect him to have
any chances at all to be directed the
changes to the Constitution are being
designed by push my he's well regime in
order to deploy the would be president
of Ukraine of considerable part of the
powers so that means that they have
calculated that they are not in a
position to win the elections and they
are trying to throw the changes to the
Constitution to diminish the power of
the future president by transferring the
part of his powers that is the
presidential vertical from the President
to the Prime Minister having in mind
that they will control they will
continue to control the power but I
think that in this case their
miscalculating provided that the
coalition play is going to be elected
president that would mean taking into
account ukrainian realities that the
correlation of forces in the iranian
panel will change and most of the
oligarchs who are in the parliament will
switch immediately to to the web will be
on the top so that would mean that we
will have the change of correlation of
major powers major political powers in
parliament couldn't before the 2006
parliamentary
the end up is private area afterwards
you know one man one may not exclude any
any option and I think that still they
are keeping you know all options open
which ma has not decided as to the
successor some people say that which man
himself made me run for Prime Minister
so it is in principle it is not
impossible sorry pal about Polly site as
a release falling apart and I don't
think it was expected by people within
assembly either it was by us outside the
SLG at least not to such degrees is now
the new partner is being formed right
now by the people from from SMD and it
means that once again we will be
witnessing the change of the flag